All right. So let's say that we look at our data
and it's clearly non-normal. Or we use a statistical test like
the Shapiro–Wilk test and find that our data's non-normal that way.
Is there anything that we can do? Well, first off there's
some math that says that we have enough data. That we
have, you know, a large enough sample size we can actually
use tests that assume normality. For example, the t test. Even
when our data is not normal. But there also exists nonparametric tests
that we can use to compare two samples. A
non-parametric test is a statistical test that does not assume
our data is drawn from any particular underlying probability distribution.
One such test is the Mann-Whitney U Test which is
also sometimes referred to as the Mann-Whitney Wilcoxan Test.
This is a test of the null hypothesis that two
populations are the same. Again I don't want to go to
in depth into the theory of how this test works,
but I did want to tell you that things
like this exist and show you that this test
can also easily be implemented in Python using Psi
Pi. We'd simply say U and P are equal
to scipy.stats.mannwhitneyu. And provides as arguments are two samples
which we'll call here X and Y. This function
will return U, the Mann-Whitney test statistic. As well
as P, which is the one sided P value
for this test. The P value here again acts as
it did for the T test. Note that the Mann-Whitney
U test simply tests whether or not these samples came
from the same population. But not necessarily which one has
a higher mean or a higher median or anything like
that. Because of this it's usually useful to report Mann-Whitney
U test results along with some other information. Like, the
two sample means, or the sample medians, or something like that.